we have breaking news regarding the
internet where a string of major
news websites including cbsnews.com were
down this morning
this is the error message you saw on
your screen when you tried to connect
the outage also appeared to affect
amazon.com's main retail website for a
period of time this morning
cbs news technology reporter dan
patterson is tracking the outages dan
what's going on
good morning so if you were an early
riser
like i am you probably check a few news
websites to get a head start on your day
including the new york times maybe
reddit
uh and we discovered what's called an
error 503 now that's when domain traffic
can't resolve to the host i know that
sounds techy
and nerdy but bear with me when you type
in a website or you search for a site
and then you click
through a bunch of servers are kind of
sending
traffic delivering traffic to a
particular address
now it turns out the company fastly is a
content delivery network or they provide
these hosting services
to a number of media sites including cbs
news now when we saw this error 503 that
was kind of a clue
because it let us know that all right a
suite of sites a whole a number of
different sites were experiencing the
same
problem if this was a major hack we
might see a diverse
number of errors instead of this one
clue
then when we look at fastly and we see
that this
is the second connective tissue the
second clue here
okay this makes us think that maybe this
was a misconfiguration instead of a hack
so
i reached out to a number of sources who
all said kind of the same thing
um we are looking at a misconfiguration
that is slowly resolving itself this
morning
but it has affected the new york times
as you said cnn twitch reddit
uk government's homepage financial times
affected a lot of sites this morning dan
thank you very much it sounds like it's
an oops not an uh oh
yeah yeah there is a difference pretty
big oops though yeah it's a big oops
somebody's in trouble